Hello, everyone!
I will kick off my YouTube Series about explained
AI methods and papers with the question: How
do we check if a neural network has learned
to solve A?
Well, the answer to this question is not so
interesting: Since we have trained the neural
network for solving A, we have training data
for A.
Then, we test how well the network solves
A on the held-out set of data and we are done.
No, come on!
Let us ask something more interesting: How
do we check if a neural network trained on
task A has learned a phenomenon specific to
task B?
And we will give the answer focusing on NLP,
but it is generalizable to many other applications,
like Computer Vision.
Since the AI field is changing so rapidly,
this video is a snapshot of the current state
of research.
Simultaneously, it is my attempt to explain
intriguing but complicated concepts, that
researchers use every day, in a simple and
understandable manner.
So let’s get back to the original question:
How do we check if a neural network trained
on task A has learned a phenomenon specific
to task B?
We start here with a neural network and supposing
it was trained on large amounts of training
data like on Wikipedia, where it “reads”
the text and has to predict masked words.
[strange voice] Can a neural network read?
This masked word prediction is our task A.
Because predicting masked words by a neural
network has been lately proven to be extremely
effective on many other tasks apparently unrelated
to masked word prediction, we want to test
this:
Is this true that if the neural network, trained
to complete missing parts of text, has also
captured interesting linguistic phenomena?
And before we can answer this question, we
have to choose one phenomenon we want to probe
for.
Checking if and how much a neural network
trained on task A, captures a specific (linguistic)
phenomenon, is referred to by terms like:
probing or diagnostic classifier or a "probing
task B".
So the task B comprises the linguistic phenomenon
we want to test for here.
Keeping it simple now, I will use the example
of sentiment expressed in text, where the
text is no longer than a paragraph.
And here, a neural network has to tell us,
if a paragraph expresses positive sentiment,
or negative sentiment.
The example could be anything else, from the
grammaticality of a sentence to natural language
inference.
Now, back again to our So in this sentiment
analysis example, the task is simple:
Now back again to our original question: How
do we check if a neural network trained on
task A has learned a phenomenon specific to
task B (in NLP)?
We wonder: How to researchers try to answer
this question?
Well, with probing.
Okay, okay, and how do we probe?
We take the network as-is, trained on task
A, and remove the last part, the one that
was responsible for mapping all the weights
encoding patterns in the data for making the
final prediction.
Now to test if this part can also do sentiment
classification, we then replace to the last
layers with another fresh classifier that
has not yet been trained to do anything.
It cannot now map the original parameters
of the neural network to sentiment classification.
Okay, then let’s train it to!
In order to keep everything preserved that
we have trained from task A, we freeze (so
leave unchanged) the old part of the network,
and this fresh part, we train.
And train it on a relatively small dataset
of sentiment classification or task B, containing
paragraphs labelled with positive or negative
sentiment.
And in this scenario, the new classifier,
our probe, is performing binary classification,
where the output is either 0 for negative
sentiment or 1 for positive sentiment.
From the way the probe trains, we differentiate
between the following scenarios:
If the classifier, trained on the small dataset
for probing, is learning fast and performing
well, then the weights we left unchanged have
been already capturing the information of
the probe task.
In the second, worse scenario, if the classifier
trained on this small dataset is not learning
anything and is barely performing better than
when it is untrained (or at the beginning
of training), then the weights of the big
neural net have been not capturing any information
about the probing task at all.
Or so it seems.
Ok now, if we would ignore the most recent
research, we would stop here.
And if you clicked on this video for getting
the answer to the original question of “How
do we check if a neural network has learned
something (in NLP)?”, then you are ready
to go, since we explained how it works on
the example of sentiment analysis how this
is done.
And the same procedure holds for many other
phenomena and is not even restricted to NLP!
Now in the following, I will be addressing
the contribution of a recent paper, where
the authors address the following problems:
Neural Networks in general, tend to overfit,
meaning that they specialize on a certain
task, “memorizing” input and output.
And this problem gets even bigger when the
size of out training set is small, and this
is usually the case for our probing task.
Overfitting happens with the classifier too,
where it is able to learn the new probing
task, but is also able to learn a completely
random probing task, where the labels have
been randomly altered.
Also, sometimes, the expected difference between
an untrained probe and a trained one, is not
as big as expected.
Can the authors do something to “save”
the standard probing from its problems?
Oh yes, they do!
They use an information-theoretic view, and
since this might sound intimidating, the idea
is elegant, and yet so simple: Additionally
to measuring how many times the neural network
with the trained probe can give right or wrong
answers, they check if the neural network
can also efficiently transmit the data.
This means: if we call our neural network
Bob and the probing classifier, Alice, the
person receiving the answers of Bob and mapping
them to labels, then: Bob sees some data,
processes it through the neural network and
sends it to Alice.
So Alice receives a message, tries to decode
and reconstruct the right label, but gives
him more credit if the message from which
she could decode the label has been short.
Instead of measuring only the capacity of
Bob and Alice to get to the right answer,
we are now additionally measuring how well
Bob could send the message in a short, compressed
form, for which we would assume, he had do
“understand more” and see patterns in
this world.
If you liked this information-theoretic approach
and want to know more, read the paper!
It is so well written, that it is really a
pleasure to read.
I have linked it in the description of the
video, below.
Thanks for watching, do not forget to like
and subscribe!
See you, next time…!